so
dragon spacex com track ground stitches
we got to see iss out the
window which was pretty neat
the largest window ever flown in spain
we have liftoff
gwen welcome to stanford thank you very much
i'm really excited to be here actually i love
this school um i've been looking forward
to this interview for a very long time as
i know have many of my classmates a bit of a
space nerd i as a kid would read all the space
books over the 60s apollo 14 was my favorite
movie i think still is my favorite movie
clean crayons the mythical flight director was a
childhood hero so it's really great to have you to
me space has always been about the next frontier
and testing the limits of what is possible
and today nobody embodies that better than spacex
and your story so with that let's get started
one of the defining characteristics of spacex
uh is is risk-taking but the same can be said
about you joining the company 20 years ago
this year after stable career in aerospace
what led you to join spacex and take that risk at
that time well first of all i want to start out by
saying thank goodness i took that risk because
i almost didn't in fact and when elon asked me
to be president in 2008 i almost didn't say yes
what a mistake that would have been um yeah so
i was in the aerospace industry i started
i started my engineering career when was it
in 86 went to chrysler motors went back to
school because i was unsatisfied with the
level of technology that i was working on there
um went back to university thought i'd get my phd
wacky so that i can't be in school again i'm gonna
go back to work and so i went to aerospace and i
think i started in 88. interestingly i started
on halloween in 1988 at the aerospace corporation
and my boss um wasn't there when i started but
came back a week later he was on vacation and
he said something about flying in on my broom in
1988 which you can't say now but he could say it
then so the world is changing even if we feel like
it's too slow um yeah so okay so started my career
in 88 um in the aerospace industry and thought
had been there for roughly 15 years roughly
and i thought look it's it wasn't a an industry
that was vibrant it wasn't innovative we weren't
moving quickly we hadn't gotten back to the moon
and i thought you know this is my last job in the
aerospace industry working for elon if we can't
do it at spacex then i'd rather sell real estate
or be a barista or you know something else i did
i wouldn't i didn't want to work in the industry
and so um i knew this would be my last job in the
aerospace industry and it will turn out to be the
case so that's super cool all right about risk
yeah you guys are about risk and i'm blabbing
around sorry okay um so it seemed risky actually i
had a very stable job i owned three percent share
of the company that i was working for which
is large for um for for for a for an employee
and uh it was a pretty safe job so this was not
a safe job and i didn't know elon well at all in
fact at that time um but i i really kind of jumped
off the cliff i was dithering around he said
he wanted me to join the company and i said
oh you know i'm fine i don't need a job and
kind of dithered for about a month and finally
like i'm such an idiot i was driving on the
freeway in l.a like what an idiot say yes so i
called him on the phone and i said bleep an idiot
and he laughed and he said welcome to the team so
you got sold on the idea right yeah had a lot of
confidence if you thought it was going to be your
last job um last job on the industry fair enough
um but your first job was vice president
of business development so now you had
to sell that idea to customers yes and
spacex was little more than a pipe dream
at the time right you were many years away
from launch what was that selling process like
you know it's interesting when you when you
don't have a product we had an ideal to sell
and it came at probably the best possible time um
you know we had the events of 911 and rapid launch
low cost access to space be it was obvious that
it was going to be very critical and so it was
great engineers i am not going
to take away in fact spacex is
the great company and does the great things
that we do because of our extraordinary staff
it's not because me it's not because of
elon and and so i was selling the team
i was selling the ideal i was selling the promise
and the hope of reason reasonably priced launch i
i still don't think launch is reasonably priced
but if you go by comparison it's much less than
it was before we're getting there yeah so let's
talk about launch and about the first rocket right
um the first rocket was called the falcon one
uh you had three unsuccessful launches it was
2008 the company was running out of money it was
the financial crisis you were promoted to present
ceo because of promises you had made customers
at this point so you'd already been promoted
and the company bet the entire company in this
one launch on the fourth launch of the falcon
one so let's watch that launch five four three
two one zero print stage one liftoff indication
one launch vehicle falcon has cleared the tower
plus 12. curious thank goodness right so uh it's
a life or death moment for the company right
um is a little more dramatic about that launch
than i am actually i figured we could pull a fifth
launch off but that was it right yeah i thought
we could get to five he thought four was it
i'm glad we didn't have to test who was right on
that one but uh yeah it was quite a relief and
what were the moms leading up to it like what was
the well this is a really this is i think it's a
hilarious story i was in scotland glasgow the iac
was having a show in glasgow so i was in scotland
to apologize discuss explain to the customers
that were on the third falcon one launch that
we failed kind of basically do a paper about that
launch and it was the night before my talk i was
in the hotel room with my husband and this is not
gonna get inappropriate um my husband was sleeping
i'm in the bathroom with the shower on typing up
a proposal for the 1.6 billion dollar con nasa
resupply to the international space station we're
literally writing the proposal i'm on the phone
with my team back in the us because we had to
update our pricing and so i had the shower running
so that my you know poor husband could sleep i'm
like punching away talking and then it's like oh
shoot we're we're about ready to launch right and
so i turned away from my proposal on my laptop to
to the launch and uh was watching it as we lift
it off i ran out to the hotel room and i didn't
care if i woke him up at this point at this stage
we lifted off and we were climbing in altitude and
um and we watched us get to orbit and
then in my like yoga pants and jammy top
ran down the hall that's probably the most
inappropriate thing i'm going to say here
today but ran down the hall knocked on all
the doors from my team that was there and we
hugged and kissed and cried and then kind of
broke into the bar in the hotel because it was
like two in the morning and they they they let us
have the champagne but it was warm but it was it
was extraordinary it was extraordinary i've always
loved how emotional a business this is right yeah
these are just incredible emotional moments right
in fact by the way to future entrepreneurs i
think it's really important to have these big
moments figure out what the big moments where
you can bring your teams together it cures a
lot of ills it really helps with morale and
it's incredible for team building so launches are
easy it's an easy spectacle to do that with but
i think it's really important to find those
kinds of moments in the development for your
future businesses so let's actually move forward
a few years your first big kind of commercial
product was the falcon 9. it was designed in part
of nasa's needs in mind to replace the internet
the space shuttle to go to the national space
station you had done a number of launches
already including seven resupply missions to
the international space station with nasa right
and the eighth one was also supposed to take
critical food supplies medical equipment
international space station but that one
didn't go as well let's watch that video
that's this is two minutes into flight daddy
coming back show us vehicle on course on track
poof yeah you had made it seem routine almost at
this point right um and then this happens you're
in crisis management mode what's the first
thing you do yeah so i was actually at my
ranch in texas on this launch it was the first
launch that uh i was not um that therefore yeah
um by the way it was also the first and
only launch that i didn't do my pre-launch
um little routine which we could chat about later
but because i was in my slippers and uh so um
i think the most important thing when you suffer
something like that is you focus everybody on the
job the task at hand right we had failure in
front of us on elon's birthday by the way that
was his birthday um which is why we don't like
to launch on his birthday it just feels like bad
karma actually um so uh you get to work i had to
do a press conference doing it remotely of course
um and we started digging through data of course
we obviously i've i flew back to hawthorne and
pulled teams together and we figured it out was it
was a weird one that one and then so this was in
on june 28 2015 and then we suffered another
failure was not a launch failure on september
1st 2016 not a little over a year later right
um and we basically blew up a satellite that
was sitting on the pad as we were going through a
pre-launch test so two failures not back to back
we had had an extraordinary success in december
of 2015 and we can come back to that as well but
this is a this is a point that i try to make
with students for sure so i think after the
crs-7 that first failure that failure that you saw
there i i felt very comfortable leading the team
through the investigation leading the team
through the physics and getting to the answer
the business wasn't really at risk i mean
failures are incredibly impactful i think
every failure we've had has either cost us
or delayed us about half a billion dollars
but i felt like i did a pretty good job in that
time frame i did not do a good job after the
failure uh when we blew up on the pet i was much
more worried about the business this particular
event um was much harder to figure out what it was
and i i definitely showed my not despair that's
probably too much but my concern i definitely
wore it on my sleeve or as my husband says i
have a billboard on my forehead and i i wore
that badly in fact so my lesson there is you
know you certainly don't want to be disingenuous
with your team and with your customers but it's
not really helpful to show your anxiety when you
know when you're suffering because your employees
are suffering worse than you are so it's really
better to keep people focused on the business
keep focused on doing great things and they had
demonstrated that they could do great work until
then too so um yeah so that's a nice little nugget
yeah thanks for sharing that so one of the things
in particular for this first failure that i find
incredible is you had six months without launches
which i'm sure you had a bunch scheduled that
were delayed right but six months later you're
launching a rocket again uh but instead of
simply focusing on getting that rocket and the
customer's payload up into space successfully
you take a huge risk as well and try to land
the booster right do you have that video and i
have that video and i know it's your favorite yes
the crown goes wild
it was a mosh pit out there was so fun why was
this so exciting okay so what's key about that
is the last launch or the launch just prior to
that one we failed you know and it's disappointing
for the employees it's disappointing for
the company but we failed our customer
this launch so we stood down we discovered
what the problem was we redesigned the rocket
to be able to land because the previous
rockets really couldn't land in that way
so we complete we did a complete upgrade on the
system while figuring out what we did to fail
and then like in complete view of the public
you go out there and you show are you are you
meant for greatness or you need to go back to the
drawing board a little bit so that was a great a
great day it was a great night we had a lot of
champagne at my house that night probably more
than i've ever drank ever i did not feel great the
next day but i did go to work i went to work um
yeah so that was an extraordinary moment for the
company just share with us a little bit why it's
so important to the whole business model yeah
sorry um well first of all no one had ever landed
a rocket before right that was the start and the
key piece of the technology necessary to reuse
rockets so some i know there are some space nerds
out there but there are many of you that are not
by the way if you are a space nerd you
should wear that proudly i certainly do
um but rockets before spacex and to some
extent the shuttle did it but but there was
there's no fully reusable launch system rockets
launch and then they either disintegrate in the
atmosphere the second stage does or they
just get dumped into the ocean right now
and so imagine what air travel would be like
if you took an airplane from san francisco
to new york and you had to toss the aircraft
after that flight like life and society in the
world would be so different if you couldn't reuse
your aircraft and so we take that same approach
with space travel that you have to be able to
reuse your rockets in order to facilitate human
access to space which i think is incredibly
important so that was the start and we had
tried many times before um we tried parachutes
but they rip off in this as speeding through the
atmosphere so that was just an extraordinary piece
of technology guidance navigation and control you
know hyper retroactive propulsion crazy hypersonic
retroactive propulsion was just amazing so that
was great and it started our ability to
refly rockets we didn't refly that one
that one is sitting outside the front
of our building in hawthorne california
you can drive by it and see it in fact it's kind
of a neat monument but we have i don't want to
say perfected because we have not perfected but we
have operationalized the ability to land rockets
refurbish them and re-fly them our goal is
to be able to do that like an airplane like
i was saying in the back room you know they said
something someone asked something about you know
rocket efficiency and we're not very efficient
we we actually aspire to be as efficient as the
airline industry and that's probably horrifying to
many of you in the audience because you probably
don't think the airline industry is particularly
efficient but it's way better than we are um so
it's still a nice model to use right yeah so
after this in 2015 this really became routine
spacex was launching dozens and dozens of trips up
into space every year um in may 2020 the beginning
of the pandemic you took another huge leap and it
involved humans right you launched two astronauts
to the national space station the first astronauts
to launch on a private vehicle and the first to
do so from american soil on any vehicle in nine
years right we were doing it with the russians
um how did you carry that responsibility
and how do you prepare the team for it
so first of all keep your head high don't show
your anxiety but i honestly hate crew launch days
i just don't like them uh it's nerve-racking it's
one thing to you know to have a have a failure
when you've got a satellite even a billion dollar
three billion dollar satellite on top you can't
put a price tag on the two to four people that are
sitting on top of that rocket and it's hurtling
through the atmosphere so it's quite anxiety
producing um it's always a huge relief to
get get dragged into orbit get dragged into
the international space station and then say
okay nasa they're yours now until
we have to bring them back downhill
six months later um so keep people focused on the
work for sure don't let them show your ex you know
don't let them see my anxiety even though i've
talked about this enough they all know i'm like
scared to death during launch days on this follow
your routine be keenly aware make sure you've got
employees that feel very comfortable talking about
hey i might have screwed this up can we go back
and look at the data and make sure that i didn't
screw this up on the rocket or the spaceship so
um yeah keep them focused on the business
don't show how nervous you are and
pray so even this has become routine now
i think you've launched four trips to the
national space station something like that so
we did bob and doug and then we just flew crs4
and then we also flew axiom yeah and then we did
jared and his team that's true okay so so seven
so let's talk about the future then because you
know um and let's talk about starship which is the
big bet you have as a future or this rocket was
previously called the big falcon rocket bfr bfr um
who who chose to rename it well
elon named it the first time
and elon named it the second time got it um there
was one in between two its i think interstellar
or something yeah yeah exactly yeah um starship
is better what's so different about this bet and
what does it mean for humanity so the difference
here for those of you that are not space geeks
this first stage goes up delivers the second stage
to carry on its way to orbit comes back so we
reuse the first stage but the second stage is now
reusable it goes to orbit it drops off the payload
takes people around the moon takes people to
mars whatever it is and then it comes back and
lands our second stage right now is not reusable
on the falcon program our third stage if you look
at a dragon is reusable not very operationally
right it lands in the ocean get helicopters and
ships to go get it out of the water take it back
clean off the salt water refurbish it and refly
it but a dragon takes currently like 90 days
we're trying to get it down to 45 and then even
faster but that's not very operationally
efficient starship is meant to launch
land on the pad on the pad the arms come and
pick up another another starship pick it up
put it back on the pad and launch within
an hour so like an airplane that's the plan
and it's supposed to take us either to shanghai
or to mars right yeah right hopefully some
version of this would take us to another star
system right which would be so great um so i
want to talk about the development of this
because there's something remarkable about
that as you mentioned it's supposed to be
fully reusable i saw many estimates online
but each one of these costs somewhere around 200
million to build that might be a wild guess um
but your product development strategy seems
to be to blow one of these up every few months
right so let's take a look at starship number
nine we're prepared by preparing to restart
two engines flip the vehicle vertical then
transition to one engine for the landing burn
so that seems expensive and completely different
to how traditional rocket technology where it's
like they make the whole rocket as perfectly
as possible they wind test it and they say
once it's perfect we try to you know flight test
it these are prototypes that you just keep going
um what's behind that way of thinking about
rocket technology so and this isn't very well
understood publicly i'm a little surprised
we don't talk more about it we are much more
focused for the starship program on production
building the system that will build the system
than we are on the rocket technology itself
i didn't touch anything no you did all right
i break hardware by walking by so this
makes me nervous um so we know how to get
rockets to orbit we know how to do that this
is a completely different one but we we're
very confident in our ability to figure out how
to do that we were much more focused on can we
produce a rocket that can get to orb like really
produce falcon we produce you know between seven
and eleven falcon first stages per year we're
producing a second stage every week right now
but what we want to be able to do is produce a
rocket a day or come much closer to automotive
because if you are going to take people to mars
you're going to go in a flotilla or a swarm i
don't even know yet right what the right term
is yet for a group of starships to head to mars
you're going to need a bunch of them and producing
five a year isn't going to get you there you
really want to launch hundreds on that cyanotic
period with mars when you're taking people there
um so we need to have a production system
build rockets much like a production system
to build cars maybe not quite so many i don't
think we need a million a year but uh we need
more than a couple hundred so it's all about the
production system so we will get this to orbit
i'm not saying that it's easy because it's very
different you'll see the way well not the orbital
part but the the landing part is very different
you know we belly flop to dissipate the heat
and then come vertical right at the last second
it's different from the way we're doing it on
falcon but we i mean we and we did it we stuck a
landing bringing it back no it wasn't from orbit
it was just from altitude it was not from orbit so
you're trying to do really hard things and i want
to talk about what that a little bit right spacex
has the most ambitious goals on the tightest of
timelines and actually quick question what's our
latest timeline on getting to mars getting to mars
oh i think we'll put people down within a decade
right so you're in charge of i know i'm crazy
you're in charge of executing on that goal to get
human beings to mars within a decade right that's
more elon than me but i'm here to help right but
how do you balance those ambitious goals right
which like maybe elon comes out and says and
getting the team comfortable that is possible
so there's a couple of strategies to do that
first of all you always aim high we have achieved
everything we have wanted to never in the timeline
we fail on timeline but that feels like the right
fail to make as opposed to not achieving
what you're trying to achieve technically um
so you demonstrate that you've been able to do
these crazy insane absurdly ambitious things
in the past you can continue you know pump people
up to do it again and you try to pull apart these
the seemingly impossible situation and how are we
going to design and develop this and you pull it
into smaller pieces you build a prototype you test
it you put prototypes you know subsystems together
and you test that and you kind of use a building
block approach to reach your goals and the team
they're very enthusiastic about it like it's
the biggest of goals rockets are super cool yeah
so you've been at spacex for over 20
years now this year yeah and now you
lead a team basically 12 000 people um what
have you learned about your leadership style
over the years what do you wish you knew
now that and you knew then that you know now
oh let me answer the other stuff first um i'm
not a regretter so it's really hard for me to
kind of go back and say oh i wish i did
this thing um i'm a very collaborative
leader actually i've got some employees here
you can tell me if i'm a bs artist here or not
i like to get to solicit people's opinions
but i'm not afraid to make a decision
i need more data than elon does to make a decision
in fact and i don't know whether that's experience
or or risk taking i don't know what it is but
i like a little bit more data but i definitely
like making decisions i like to hear
the conversation until you're done and
you have to make a decision and it's rare
that you get people to agree on any topic
right so you collect the best data that you can
you listen as hard as you can you ask questions
you bring more data back and then you gotta go
yeah um so a slightly different question your
job is to run the business right sometimes things
come up in the organization that are core to the
culture uh that are according to who you are as an
organization um the sexual misconduct allegations
against elon last week are just maybe one example
of that i'm wondering how you think about those
moments those moments of truth and how you
think about responding to different stakeholders
so i think leaders in any business face adversity
and really hard challenges and i what's most
important is that you first of all you think hard
about what happened what the response is going to
be and i think you just have to be really honest
with yourself about what the right approach is
i did send a letter i came out last
night very exciting for this particular
discussion here i did send a letter to
employees they were screaming to hear from me
and i was advised to not send that letter
not by legal but by my press team and i said you
know what i first i have to speak to the people i
have to speak to my employees they're you know the
reason why spacex is what it is and i care deeply
about them but i knew i would no matter which way
i played that someone was going to be unhappy with
me but i i had to say it i have worked for
elon for 20 years i don't believe he could
have done what was what he was accused of but he
is imperfect right he's imperfect i'm imperfect
and i thought being honest about that was
the right approach regardless of what my team
told me to write or not what was left out of that
letter by the way is the end where i basically say
we are spacex is who we are because of you and if
you ever feel uncomfortable at work please call me
right so that part's always left off right um
at any rate so you face adversity and i think
the only way to get through it is to make sure
you understand the situation to the greatest
extent you can and then be honest with yourself
and pick a path and and do it and don't be afraid
to say you made a mistake if you make a mistake
right yeah i'm irish that's very irish by the way
to admit you were dummy and i'm not admitting that
in this case by the way i'm just saying one should
be willing to do that speaking of mistakes i've
heard that spacex has a culture of feedback that's
something we take very seriously here at the
gsb as well we have a whole class where we learn
how to give feedback feedback
is a gift as a continuous motto
of the school almost i'm wondering how
spacex operationalizes that in the day-to-day
so critically important feed 360 feedback and
immediate the sooner you get feedback the better
off you are that's a golden nugget of data on how
you are impacting your co-workers your company the
project so that feedback is so critical so give
feedback as quickly as you can and we always
try to tell people to do it our review system
we require that you get reviewed 360 feedback
from at least three you know sometimes in
you know if you've got employees that have
you know that are really great in some areas
and really not great in other areas you try
to solicit more feedback to figure out what's
going on in those areas and try to work with
them to figure out how you can get people to this
place where it's all contribution all the time
so so it's in our review system uh we talk about
it at the first day of work please you know
give feedback um but engineers and well you know
it's not really human nature to be willing to
look someone in the eye and say hey that was not
helpful not super helpful could you do it this
way you know be objective try to not personalize
it in almost every case and it feedback could be
technical it doesn't have to be like hey you were
a total jerk to me and i'm really mad about it
um but in almost every case the person at least in
my experience person is not malinten not intending
to do bad things they either made a mistake they
were unaware um so i think approaching it as
not part taking it not personal but just talk
about how this situation impacted you or how this
person's work caused your work to not be great
you couldn't finish your project or whatever
it's just really important that's exactly
what we we preached here as well yep um
before we go to q a and i know that a lot of
great questions in the audience two questions
again about the future first and you already made
a reference to this what comes after mars yeah so
um we are not working on a ship that yet has the
propulsion technology to take us to other star
systems but i certainly hope that mars is that
example that shows that humans can live beyond
planet earth and that we will focus on propulsion
technologies or some way of getting to a place
that would otherwise take four thousand or five
thousand years so i'm very excited about that it
will not happen in my lifetime but i hope that
some of the work that we're doing will kick off
the aspiration to go do that
like the shows that you watch
you know we we can't and they're always about war
by the way star wars like what is that i don't
star trek is not necessarily about war but it's
still military i don't know why it is that way
but um hopefully we can go there in a civilian way
and meet other sentient beings and that would be
great yeah that would be quite something so for uh
for this for the second question i actually want
to bring us back to earth to this auditorium
because many of us are thinking about our
very immediate futures i checked this morning i
graduate in two and a half weeks as do many of
my classmates here you're our last view from the
top speaker of the year you have the stage what
advice would you have for us as we embark on the
next chapter of our lives so it's a very simple
statement and i'll follow it up with a couple of
examples you want to take risks in your career
you absolutely want to take risks yeah maybe in
your life too although you have to balance right
you got to balance it um i almost said no to elon
when he asked me to join spacex would have been so
i would look back i'm not a regretter that is
the one thing that i would go back and regret
i almost said no when elon asked me to be
president because i really loved my job my
colleagues my brother and sister vps were great
compatriots and i thought it might be weird to
be the boss so i almost said no um and i'm so
glad that i didn't but it felt like a risk to to
to say yes there and then this is a more personal
risk um so when i first met my current husband
husband number two sorry um we had our first date
and i thought he was roughly my age roughly my age
and then he said something about the gulf war and
you know wanting to have been a pilot i was like
go form like help and i were in the car
and i looked over i'm like how old are you
and he he was about eight years
younger than me and i was like
not interested why would i go
out with this infant no way
and and luckily luckily i i didn't take that
little voice in my head and i took the risk and
dated a much younger man and happily married so
it's not really silly but a little personal but
i almost said i am not going to date someone
that's 8 years younger than me that is weird
anyhow took the risk paid off what uh what
a great note to end on so with that um
yeah
before we close and we are almost out
of time i want to do a traditional view
from the top lightning round oh okay
ready i'm very terrible at these okay
would you rather live in the univer universe or
the metaverse i'm not sure what the metaverse
is by the way but i think i'm all universe
all the time there's a lot of students here
who know what the better verse i don't yeah um
what are your favorite pre-launch rituals which
you mentioned before oh i put uh the inside of
my shoes with sticky notes that say scotland
on them so i am in scotland for every launch
because we got to orbit for the first time when i
was in scotland yep and the only gross thing about
that is there if i don't take them out right away
you like stepping on paper and it kind of
disintegrates and then you get like feet
paper all over the place and you really
have to vacuum it up it's pretty gross
toast lunch rituals i don't have a post launch
ritual actually favorite celebration champagne
every time no every launch
well we're launching a lot
maybe not every time maybe not every time
certainly not during the day
at work that's an at-home thing
favorite space movie firefly and that's the show
but there also was a movie firefly hands down
and you have a starship at your disposal
it's yours you can go anywhere on earth
or into space where would you take it i go to
the moon orbit or land i would like to land
successfully yeah i love the moon and why
the moon and not mars mars is six months
um it's further uh i don't like to camp so
you're you're you're traveling for six months
to really camp in the most extreme way humans
have ever camped whereas camping on the moon
it feels like ah if you hate it you just just
come home or you can you can put up with it
for a couple of days and then you just get
home mars you're kind of stuck for two years
please welcome me in thanking grandchildren
you